et
7h44 sur rmc votre invité jean jacques
bourdin jean marc jancovici enseignant à
l'école des mines paristech et
consultant sur les questions
énergétiques
dormez tranquilles jusqu'en 2100 et
autre malentendu sur le climat et
l'énergie aux éditions odile jacob jean
marc jancovici bonjour ça vous fait
sourire dit moi c'est une fête sourires
et de bonne humeur
vraiment je suis de bonne humeur le
matin oui oui malgré parce que la
planète est en danger vous le dit aussi
oui je puis qui a dit il est trop tard
pour être pessimiste et vous savez quand
il était foutu voilà donc alors la
planète en danger
non nous on est en danger ou d'ailleurs
oui nous le rire est en danger ça ne
vous gêne pas tellement oui oui nous
sommes vraiment en danger
nous sommes en danger oui parce que
beaucoup beaucoup de gens ne prennent
pas conscience de cette urgence
climatique
alors on a malheureusement un épisode
dramatique qui vient de nous le rappeler
assez facile de faire une connexion
entre ce qui s'est passé à paris il ya
quinze jours ce qui s'est passé ce qu'on
appelait les printemps arabes qui ont
été à l'origine de toute cette affaire
qui sont déclenchées il ya quelques
années et les questions de changement
climatique et d'énergie
oui on peut faire le lien entre les
faire le lien absolument c'est du reste
l'objet d'un des chapitres de
l'excellent livre que vous n'étiez mais
jean marc jancovici on va parler du
nucléaire on va parler de des énergies
renouvelables mais parlons des énergies
fossiles d'abord je regardais un chiffre
attendait faut que je retrouve ce
chiffre ce qui m'a frappé
les subventions aux énergies fossiles
452 milliards de dollars l'année
dernière contre par exemple 121
milliards $ pour les renouvelables les
énergies fossiles sont toujours
subventionné énergies fossiles c'est le
pétrole c'est le gaz et le charbon
oui toujours subventionné j'ai je vous
avouerai que j'ai pas mis mon nez dans
le winter des subventions parce qu'il ya
des gens qui comptent comme subvention
le fait qu'on donne vraiment de l'argent
et il ya des gens qui comptent comme
subvention le fait qu'on taxe pas autant
sa qu'autre chose
oui on mélange un peu les deux le fait
est que de toute façon on a toujours
aidé ces énergies parce que c'est ces
énergies qui ont permis ce qu'on a
coutume d'appeler le mode de vie
industrielle ou le mode de vie de la
civilisation et son passé alors un jour
oui
maintenant le un jour tout dépend si on
parle de la semaine prochaine ou dans
deux mille ans par contre ce qui est sûr
c'est que si on veut préserver un climat
stable
il va falloir faire avec de moins en
moins oui les français on aime bien
raisonné noir et blanc sait on aime bien
se dire on passe du tout ou rien en fait
pour et la question se pose beaucoup
plus ans il faut faire progressivement
avec de moins en moins c'est plutôt
comme ça qu'il faut voir la chose donc
de moins en moins d'énergie fossile
on n'est pas d'accord remplacé par quoi
parce qu'il faut de l'énergie alors
remplacé par pour partie pas d'énergie
ça s'appelle les économies oui bah oui
et pour partie d'autres formes d'énergie
et dans les autres formes d'énergie on
met deux grande énergie par fossiles qui
sont les renouvelables et nucléaires oui
on a les deux
sur les deux énergies qui doivent
remplacer l'énergie alors il ya des pays
où celle déjà été fait parce que c'était
facile de le faire et c'est notamment le
cas quand vous avez beaucoup de montagne
et beaucoup de forêts dans un pays
prenez la suède oui 9 millions
d'habitants sur 350 mille kilomètres
carrés donc presque la surface de la
france
oui 70 % de forêts il n'utilise pas de
pétrole dans l'industrie pas de gaz dans
l'industrie pas de gaz dans le chauffage
pas de pétrole dans le chauffage il
arrive est ce qu'un jour il y aura des
pays qui pourront se passer totalement
d'énergies fossiles alors ça dépend de
la quantité d'énergie qu'on veut
consommer et donc on dit autrement de la
consommation qu'on veut avoir
si on veut avoir une voiture d'une tonne
par personne à sept milliards
d'habitants on n'y arrivera pas oui si
on veut avoir quelque chose qui permette
de rester maître de son destin
oui les moins que le niveau de
consommation qu'on a aujourd'hui on peut
l'envisager
et ce sera d'autant plus facile que l'on
met encore une fois renouvelable et
nucléaire dans un même paquet oui vous
dites il y aura un accord à la coop 21
mais ça ne veut rien dire il ya eu un
accent ne veut rien dire
un accord à kyoto oui je me suis amusé
enfin si l'on s'amuse comme on peut à
regarder comment avez évolué les pays
qui avaient ratifié kyoto les pays qui
avaient pas ratifié kyoto
c'était en 97 parler alors ça ne fait
pas de différence
non si autrement si vous regardez à
quelle vitesse les pays ont entre
guillemets décarbonés ou par leurs
économies eh bien vous vous rendez
compte qu'il ya pas de différence entre
les pays qui ont signé au qu'il faut un
accord contraignant
ça ne peut ce n'est pas alors ce qu'on
appelle contraignant dans le jargon
onusien
dans le langage des nations unies en
fait c'est pas contraignant au sens où
vous et moi on l'entend c'est à dire si
vous ne respectez pas je vous envoie les
gendarmes ou les chars et les avions
ça ça n'existe pas on peut pénaliser
financièrement par les pays qui ne ça ne
relève pas des nations unies ça se passe
ailleurs cette affaire chasse passe à
l'om c'est ça se passe dans les
barrières douanières ça se passe mais ça
se passe pas aux nations unies donc ce
qui se passe aux nations unies c'est que
les gens disent c'est important de
continuer à s'en occuper
donc c'est un point de départ c'est
jamais un point d'arrivée oui jean marc
jancovici
on va pas échapper à la décroissance
dites-vous on y est déjà alors dans tous
les pays occidentaux on y est déjà d'une
certaine manière quand vous regardez la
production industrielle elle est passée
par un maximum dans tous les pays
occidentaux en 2007 et depuis 2007 elles
baissent alors nous on a de beauvais
ministre chacun sait ça donc elles
baissent en france mais elles baissent
aussi aux états unis elles baissent en
suède elles baissent en espagne elles
baissent en italie elles baissent au
japon et elle a même baissé aux
etats-unis dans la quasi-totalité des
secteurs sauf le secteur énergétique
à cause de ce qui s'est passé chez eux
donc en fait on y est déjà
et c'est bien pour ça qu'on commence à
voir aujourd'hui des gens dont le métier
c'est de gérer de faire mieux avec moins
donc quand vous regardez une bière bien
prenons airbnb oula blaquart s'est déjà
des gens qui savent faire mieux avec
moins
quelques mots vous dit le risque encore
sur le risque nucléaire vous dit le
risque nucléaire est beaucoup moins
grave que le risque du réchauffement
climatique
je vais vous dire quelque chose qui va
pas vous étonner le risque nucléaire en
france il est sur-représentée parce que
le nucléaire tombe dans quelque chose
que j'appelle le syndrome astérix vous
savez astérix que j'adore c'est le petit
malin agile qui a raison contre le gros
balourd stupide donc en france on adore
ça donc dès qu'il ya un petit qui
violent contre un gros le petit aréna il
à notre sympathie donc on a plutôt envie
de lui donner raison
et dans le débat sur le nucléaire le
petit guide contre le gros c'est l'anti
nucléaire donc on a plutôt envie de se
dire qu'il a raison
en fait quand on regarde les faits on se
rend compte que malheureusement il a
souvent tort que le nucléaire c'est
moins affreux que l'idée qu'on veut bien
s'en faire et donc les risques liés au
nucléaire sont considérablement plus
faible que les risques liés à un
changement climatique de grande ampleur
merci jean marc jancovici